david barton's family have been farming
this land in gloucestershire for four
generations but he fears for the future
tenant farmers and small family farms
like myself are really at risk that's a
real concern
his business is beef but he doesn't know
how much he'll get under the new payment
scheme for farmers the biggest
disappointment for me is that food
production isn't at the very heart of it
it absolutely should be
and if it isn't if we have to import
food from all around the world that
can't be good
the government's environmental land
management scheme will replace current
payments but farmers say they've been
given so little information they don't
know how it'll work i've been engaged
with this for about four years now as
it's been sort of progressing through
and i'm no wiser now than when i first
started looking at it
at the moment farms get direct payments
that focus on the amount of land owned
the new scheme will include funding for
landscape recovery projects like
rewilding as well as payments to farm
more sustainably a report from mps
raises serious concerns
they think they can take this vast
amount of land out of production and
still produce the same amount of food by
being more productive i think that is
naive at best at worst it's failing the
nation because we need to really
consider how we're going to feed them as
part of the new scheme direct payments
to farmers will reduce by 55
over the next three years before being
phased out completely that would reduce
the average annual net profit of farms
in england to 22
800 pounds a full of 53
compared to previous years
and there's a warning that more than a
third of farms will actually make a loss
but the government says it wants to see
profitable farming businesses producing
nutritious food and will safeguard food
security it adds that schemes are
voluntary and farmers will be able to
choose which actions work best for their
businesses
the environment secretary says that farm
incomes have improved significantly
since the uk voted to leave the eu
adding that they'll never be a better
time to improve the way farmers are
rewarded but farmers say they need
detail so they can plan for the years
ahead
they're urging the government to work
with them to come up with a way forward
becky johnson sky news gloucestershire